and now Hiro has it again stun 643 left
in the first half a step back the butler
guarded by chris dunn butler goes right
butler comes in after hero for three
[Applause]
beau puts the shooter Tyler hero in the
pic so he pops back to the three if they
double-team Jimmy he's left open and
that's exactly what happens Tyler no
hesitation again instead of BAM sent it
it's the shooter Tyler hero and he
flares back Jimmy keeps his composure on
the drive and kick back and oh my I'll
tell you this guy has confidence beyond
his years John first of all he said a
terrific screen his second of all
cold-blooded the perfect release it
brought rain and P the Chicago I has
confidence beyond his years John first
of all he said a terrific screen his
second of all cold blooded the perfect
release it brought rain and pain the
Chicago 30 minutes left in overtime
Bulls weighted 102 299 Butler circling
hero for 3-0 serves adopted
24 watts of downtown
[Applause]
then almost fumbles that somehow comes
up with it on the kick-out all five
bulls in the faith the tiler hero
licking his chops go ahead give me
another one he's he's waving his arms
saying he her hear her and he knows
that's going in go ahead and fire that
arrow